hi
everyone who's just joined i'm waiting
for
people's audios to connect thank you
very much
for joining
launches for blend rep in multiple
myeloma but trilogy and asthma
and a new indication we have tamlin we
have lisa we have catherine we have leo
thanks um all for joining um
we've only got an hour so i'll i'll go
straight in so
hello everyone welcome um this is a an
hour-long discussion around the future
of diagnostics
so before i hand over to emmanuella bats
he's the head of the research business
at saitiva
and he'll be moderating the discussion
some housekeeping information from me
my name's sophie white um i think i've
met all of you before i'm the
communications manager
for the research business of sativa
so first thing to note is this
presentation is being recorded
and will be available on demand in our
online virtual diagnostic summit which
is taking place today
and there's details of which i'll share
with you at the end
so members of the media i see you've
joined welcome
so when we get to the q a you'll have a
chance to briefly introduce yourself
and your publication so for now as you
as you are please keep yourself on mute
during the discussion
there are three ways to ask a question
firstly you can write in the
in the public chat on zoom secondly if
you prefer to verbally share you can
raise your hand during
using the hand icon and once prompted by
me you can come off me
to ask the question to the panelists
here
and finally if you want to ask a
question anonymously you can send me a
direct message
so we'll pause for questions twice
during this session so
please make sure you send them in early
and
finally it's worth noting that our
panelists are all here in
in a personal capacity so the opinions
they
express are their own and may not
necessarily represent the views of their
company
so with that i'm going to pass over to
emmanuel about
thank you sophie i hope you can all hear
me well
thank you for joining and particular
thank to our
four panelists for being with us uh
today um you know before we we start
maybe a bit of the background here i
mean obviously
the past couple of months have been
unprecedented for
from a lot of perspective and certainly
for the diagnostic industry
um it's with a massive amount of stress
i think we've seen an incredible
response but at the same time obviously
areas and opportunities for for learning
and that's what we
hope we cover uh today
so you know the panel here we've tried
to regroup
really members of the panel here that
have a
great diversity of background and
experience and
uh you'll hear more about what they do
what their company do
and their insights to this very
particular year as we
as we go through and in order to get us
started um and before we go into uh deep
dive questions
i'm just gonna do a quick lightning
round i'm gonna ask each of the
panelists there's key take away
from from this year um and maybe uh
david from sapiads if you don't mind if
you don't mind starting
uh this day first thing from cepheud um
yeah i think the uh the main uh
point of what uh what i'll be sharing in
this session
is is examples of how
the diagnostics industry can respond
quickly to a new threat
but also how we need to be considering
ways to adapt more quickly in the future
and be
better ready as well as we did for
introduction of diagnostics quickly we
can do better and we
need to do better and so preparing for
the next pandemic is
going to be an important endeavor after
this this wave passes
thank you david from gene drives
i think for me key learning this year
was
um that you you know you often hear
business leaders talk about the
importance of a
shared vision and goals in a business to
get everybody
rallied around and accomplishing and and
i think you know our
our experience is probably shared by a
lot of people
that um it was sort of easy to do this
year all of our r d
teams our commercial teams really
rallied around a cause that everyone
understands and
and uh although i agree with with with
david that we can do better
i i do think it's pretty amazing as an
industry
what we've managed to do this year all
sharing a common
vision and cause and reason for being
thank you dave and the first day of the
of the panel and you know
you don't have to be called dave to be
part of this panel but it just just
happened so so
save it from diagnostic steve um
i think for me the uh the key thing this
year
um and i've been in the industry nearly
30 years and i truly believe that this
is the
the the first year that diagnostic
testing
is has been recognized and has truly
been valued
and not just for um its role in tackling
the global
healthcare healthcare pandemic but also
in general
um so i think finally diagnostics has
been recognized and
you know a strong diagnostics industry
is going to be the focus
for many governments as a key strategic
um asset
going forward i think the other um just
to highlight what
dave and dave have said as well um you
know being as a developer
of sars culture antigen test you know we
feel again uniquely
that are in almost an infinite market
opportunity and that's really changed
the basis of competition
so that spurred a lot more collaborative
activity a lot more open collaboration
effectively pre-competitive type
behavior
um which i hope endures beyond
this pandemic but the industry really
has
come together very well not just
together as companies
but with the other stakeholders such as
governments funding bodies regulators
and to really try and provide solutions
that can help tackle the pandemic
thank you david
my middle david by the way
from the middle is david
you know i i think it has been been lots
of good lessons this year right i mean i
i think
specifically well i suppose specific to
to to the point on on diagnostics being
recognized
you know i think yeah now diagnostics
has reached the point where it's not
just something that people are going to
do go to quest laboratory and get a
blood job done
once a year and you know get meaningless
results to them
and then move on right so i think the
industry's really crossed across it and
into a new frontier there where it's
actually relevant to people
um i think specifically the pandemic
response has been there's been lots of
good lessons
there's been a lot of very human
mistakes along the way as as the
industry has evolved and governmental
responses have evolved um
but it's been i think amazing to see
that the levels of collaboration that
that have come to the fore
both in private industry and in
government industry partnerships and
and to see people really think this
through you know not we're technologists
for product developers um
but so it's been interesting to see
people really think it through all the
way to implementation
not just focus on the on the technology
but but actually how this gets
implemented in lots of different
environments
uh for lots of different purposes i
think there's still a lot to build on
here um
you know one of the things for us um
you know is what watching the
infrastructure build out right now and
uh you know i think that there's still
lots to do there to make sure that the
infrastructure that's been put in place
for the industry is sustainable
right and then that this response is is
actually replicable if it's needed in
the future
um and is maintained in the meantime
um right and i think you know that's
that's uh
that's that's probably that's going to
be our first area of focus is
infrastructure because i hear i i think
you know
what we've seen at scientific only
reflects everything you said it the
collaborative spirit the fast response
to the challenge
but i think what we've also gone through
and what the
patients are seeing is just there
there's been there's been challenges in
scale up
and ramp up and capacity to deliver and
i think a lot of the constraints are on
supply chain so
it's going to talk about supply chain
for a couple of minutes and
maybe start with you uh dave at gene
drive i mean
any takeaways from how you manage your
supply chain
expectations from your suppliers uh
things that you've learned that you
would like to do better in the future
um yeah listen i think the experience is
probably going to differ from the size
of your company and the robustness of
supply chain i mean we've been working
um
since march to develop two two products
one
one with sativa we we worked on um a
ready to go
pcr 96 well format that can sort of run
on
third-party pcr platforms and um
you know in that format having all the
components together means that from a
lab perspective the workflow is
straightforward they don't have to
prepare reagents uh and then we are also
working on a point of care
uh version that you can do rapid testing
from saliva
uh when that when the patient's present
um but but i
i think that you know when if i sort of
think back to
march uh you know the reality is you
need to move very rapidly right
and and also we saw a worldwide
draw on common reagents enzymes
uh dntps whatever you know antibody
components all sorts of things
um so i think every company was from a
supply chain standpoint
in a similar uh in a similar situation
so
um i think we can see that companies
that were able to respond quickly first
of all
leverage their existing technologies
right their existing supply chains
existing methods of working um quickly
you know they were able to repurpose
what they had
uh and and companies trying to develop
things from scratch
uh you know weren't able to do things as
quickly
so i think for us the key thing is that
we lent on suppliers that we already
knew
um that we already had relationships
with that we had contracts in place
and i think also that we were confident
in you know we
we knew them and we understood the
quality of their products
and because we knew them we had the
relationships we could sort of
um you know we we could get in that sort
of
same boat together you know trying to
trying to solve problems you know so
like in the case of our high throughput
test with your team at sativa
um you know we we generally worked on an
assay together
right like our r d teams got together
and tried to figure out you know
how to do this and as i i sort of
intimated you know we
worked with the sativa team and cardiff
for probably five years right so
we knew the quality system we knew the
people we knew we know everything
worked so i think you know there are
natural places that you're going to go
to for supply chain
um the other thing i would just comment
which is maybe a slightly different
thing is just the financial side of it
again for smaller companies you know
where we were put in the position like
lots of
other companies of having really prime
supply chains with cash
you know to secure products for for the
future
which is difficult when you really don't
know what demand and
commercial execution is going to look
like you know when you're when you're
literally right at the start
and would you say i mean i think what
what what we've observed here at
psychiatrist is there was this massive
demanding
in q2 lack of visibility a little bit of
panic by
to be to be very honest i think what you
know
i guess the two three things that we've
been working on to make it
better is i think it requires a lot of
transparency with your key customers to
have better visibility
uh i mean we've added capacity right
very clearly
very very early on they're still
building it up um
and i think you know what we are also
deploying probably with a little bit
more rigor than we had with the past is
a program we call the security of supply
where we really work really hard with
our suppliers look at dual source when
needed
but i i think like you said you know
trust our historical and built on our
historical partner but just as
i guess more rigor in the way we we
manage we manage our supply chain so i
think it's gonna
you know we i feel like we're passed
through the crisis
phase uh certainly higher volume but
much more manageable
and i think there are learnings for the
for for the for the future
uh i think you know david's at
sofia so you're you're you're you're
leading the technology you're still
forcibly you're also the cmo for that
diagnostics
like to get back to what you said very
early on which is the speed of
development
and suddenly i think safia was one of
the first companies to have
a test available on the market anything
you take from that period in how this
product was brought to market that could
help for the future
yes uh so i would i will uh echo what
uh dave david budd said about the
leveraging pre-existing technologies in
our case
we're able to leverage the pre-existing
work that we've done
for our flu rsv test and we just
basically replaced
the reagents for flu and rsv with
carnivores but even with
that we still had some work to do
because
in pcr often
uh the creations don't always play
nicely in the same sandbox
and so we actually had a fair amount of
optimization
and we didn't have the benefit of
clinical sample access early on so we
had to create
realistic mock clinical specimens with
spiked material control material was
actually
one of the biggest limitations uh early
on
because we couldn't work with live virus
we
had to uh work with a collaborator to
get access to
uh a facility to culture
live virus we also had to work with
partners to come up with control
materials that were not
infectious to be able to work with
but given all those challenges that sort
of hit simultaneously
uh we were able to come up with
christmas eve's authorization over about
a six-week period of formal development
with about two weeks of pre-development
work
on the front end that started within
days of getting the secrets
of the novel viruses
um so all in all a very uh
expedited rapid process we had to
[Music]
organize some multi-center clinical
trials
uh in parallel with the development
process so as soon as the product was
manufactured and before it was uh
emergency is authorized
we had the tests being used in five
different laboratories
in the u.s and several in europe getting
data back from their
their current standards
along with our data and so we had
confidence upon launch that this was
going to work
but clearly a highly parallelized
process for development and depending
heavily on the pre-existing design
and the existing supply chains for
the test components thank you thank you
dave
uh brandon i mean as the ceo of dc and
you actually help companies develop
their
their assets uh how do you balance speed
of development
with quality and what have you observed
there well i suppose you know the
development happens on a spectrum
obviously right
[Music]
and this was the the historical or the
that have evolved for for product
development of course with the last 30
years or so really really
really depend on uh in a heavily
regulated environment
tend more towards the less risky end of
the spectrum prior to release i think
that
the one thing this situation has done
obviously is shifted the point where we
draw the lines in that spectrum right
we're releasing products where the
industry is releasing products
earlier in the development cycles and
that it does come with risk right so it
comes at risk from a performance
perspective
um it also comes with risk to the to the
developers and the manufacturers
ultimately if
if there isn't an understanding of the
fact that you know the gaps
frankly need to be filled in right um
the the assays many of the answers on
the immunoside particularly that were
released early obviously weren't
weren't terribly robust didn't have
access to good samples didn't have
access to good binding reagents and and
suffered as a result of it and
and i think it's still probably true
that you know many of the assays have
gone through the eu a cycle
you know may not survive a a more
rigorous regulatory cycle you know which
which is going to come back
you know it's just a question of when um
so i think that you know the lesson for
anybody in this in this environment is
yes circumstances are forcing us to to
launch early
and there's there's certainly a societal
need to
to do so under the right conditions with
the right product but
um you know there's commercial risk to
that and there's there's this risk to
good data
um it has for us all to look at our work
practices i think and it has made us all
a little more efficient as well
um so there's definitely pros and a as
well as comes to the situation so
um you know it's a lot of good product
in the market now too
right right um thank you thank you
brandon
sophie do we want to pose for uh
questions maybe
yeah let's let's pause a second so i
just want to give uh
the the people from the media and the
time chance if you want to
come off me and if you have a question
here we've covered you know
uh the big topics of the year which is
all about
covenant supply and also the the
development challenges so speed of
development the pros and cons of that
so wonder if anyone has any questions um
in regard to
to those topics or anything else
hi sophie it's uh tamlyn oliver at
biocompare
hi welcome um so dave person said
at the beginning that uh he was thinking
about preparing for the next pandemic
and i wondered if he could expand on
that
um yeah i think i think it's going to be
increasingly important
for um
test developers and designers to build
in
uh what i would call broad range
capability
to cover more than the target of current
interest
this is probably more possible with
nucleic acid tests than it is with
antibody based tests where
it takes a lot of work to find the
antibody that cross-reacts with
multiple pathogens within a group um
but it can be done uh with nucleic acid
testing
it's uh very possible to identify
regions of
uh of viral families essentially which
are
conserved among all members of that
family
um and so i think the um
the the focus of the next uh
round of development activities uh
should include
at least a component of building broad
range capabilities so we are not
left completely unprepared in the
context
of the next pandemic it is entirely
possible to develop
a broad range target for
all of the sars bat beta coronavirus
family members so the next so sar cov3
uh emerges uh we'll be ready with
at least something that will tell us
that that
a novel sars chronovirus is present
that's possible to do with pandemic
influenza
as well it's possible to do
with the mers family of chronoviruses
and yet there are still important gaps
that we need to prepare for
which is to prepare for disease acts
uh for something we really have not seen
before
uh examples would be a nepa
virus that came close to being a
pandemic a few years ago
with high degree of transmissibility
and a high level of mortality
so having a measles-like transmission
pathway
combined with an ebola-like mortality
percentage
is a is a horrible thing to contemplate
nobody has to my knowledge an assay
ready to go for an epoch virus
so building in capacity to
allow systems to be modified more
quickly
building inventory so that third party
reagents can be
combined and deployed
to run on available existing
testing capacity on a
decentralized basis to meet local needs
of a local outbreak
would be an important element of getting
ready for the future as well
great thank you thank you dave and i
believe
leo has a question on the line here from
360 diagnostic so
i'll let him go ahead and ask that
question
thanks um hi guys leo from 360dx so
i'm really interesting and interested in
this whole area of
asymptomatic testing and you know how
important
uh it could be to helping all of us
everybody the whole industry in the
world mitigate the pandemic
and then if it is vital in your view
what's it going to do to to demand and
do we have
the capacity to actually do
enough testing of asymptomatic
individuals
so i'd just like to hear your thoughts
around that that area
uh well maybe i can start um leo yes
um i agree i mean the really what we
really need to do we need to have the
capability of testing
everybody um and testing everybody
frequently um because at the moment
it's it's mostly uh people with symptoms
are symptomatic that get tested
and i know in some countries such as
here in the uk you you um you can't
actually get a test unless
you're symptomatic so um it's the
ability to be able to test
everybody as frequently as possible um
and i think we're going to come on to
this later in the in the discussion
you know what testing format can enable
that what tests can be
made available at that scale we're
talking about billions
literally billions of tests every year
so a test that's good enough um to
detect infectious
people it doesn't necessarily have to
detect
all infected people um you know the
ability to test frequently
and gives you some compensation for
a lack of sensitivity for example but as
long as you're
detecting accurately detecting those
that are likely to spread the
the disease so that really um then
speaks to
um a massive demand a demand that we
can't currently satisfy
at all i mean current manufacturing
capacity
is orders of magnitude lower um it has
been scaled up
um but i think the
the the the lack of capacity to
manufacturing
tests in those numbers is actually the
biggest challenge that we face
um to enable that that approach
and and i think you know we will get
back to that uh
maybe david on that manufacturing
capacity especially for the
for the uk but maybe just building on
that on the question i mean brandon
you're also in the space of rapid
testing i mean any thoughts
uh to follow up on on dave to answer
those those questions
yeah i mean i i certainly agree with the
with the with the need for the
uh for the test um
it's it's likely to be essential to
reopening i think
you know again one of the one of the
things we have to we have to consider
is is obviously worldwide demand
you know so we're we're not just
considering first world cases in this in
this instance so
um you know creating the infrastructure
to to support that kind of production
um locally uh internationally in in the
places where these tests
are going to be needed it's it's a
massive challenge
and it's you know something that's that
we think about a lot obviously is is
supply chain um and quality of tests but
something i think gets overlooked quite
a bit is is actually the knowledge gap
um and and how we actually build
the the knowledge base in places where
that kind of production can be supported
uh how do we train the people how do we
how do we get people
up and running on you know it's one
thing to put up a production line for a
billion units or something it's quite
another to keep it running
you know so um i think there's there are
enormous gaps
in the in the infrastructure from that
perspective
and not just from the materials in the
equipment standpoint so yeah i think
it's it's an enormous challenge and it's
a it's it's going to be a
multi-year project
there's probably an element as well
around who needs to be tested
but i think the idea that you know we'll
test everyone in the world you know once
a week or something like that
i don't think we'll get there right but
being a bit more targeted around
you know transmission points or
um uh you know particularly vulnerable
populations or people i think is
probably
you know an area it'll it'll end up in
and there's a follow-up please sure go
ahead
um so we've seen how important pcr
testing
has been to to helping mitigate the
pandemic and now we've seen
fairly recently um some antigen-based
tests being
getting eua and a lot more of them
getting
ce marking as well so our point of care
test is going to be really key to
to helping mitigate these circumstances
going forward as well
how important is that element and how do
you see
the interplay between point of care pcr
and and antigen tests
david do you want to um do you want to
take that question
um sure i can take
i can take part of it um so yeah i think
uh you know it's clearly pcr um
testing in a laboratory um offers the
most accurate potentially the most
accurate
test but it's very difficult to scale
and we can't rely on
using pcr to give everyone access to a
test or however many people need
to be tested so if we did then you know
a lot of people just wouldn't
get tested so i think there's there's
definitely a very significant
and critical role for uh decentralized
testing
um uh pc uh point of care uh pcr point
of care lamp
um etc does play a role um
and then as you decentralize that
further you know right down to you know
individuals testing themselves and then
that's where the the lateral flow
technology
will come into play so it's it's really
a it's really
what we're going to need is a
combination of
all the different test modalities
because they all have different
applications
and have a you know our have a fit for
particular
um use cases as they're called in the
industry or
um or settings um but all of them will
be required
and to contribute to the testing
capacity and some will be
you know more appropriate in some
settings than
uh than in others um
yeah so i i think there's a real rule
for for all of them they're all
complementary
and brendan maybe on the readiness of
those tests
right because like leo said i mean some
of them are going through
emergency approval in the u.s some of
them are see marked i mean what's your
assessment on the readiness of this
antigen test from what you're seeing
i think that there's tremendous progress
being made on the antigen side
um you know there's uh there's an
astonishing backlog in
in the fda right now i think that the
number i most recently heard was
2800 euas in the queue
um and there's a decent number of those
that are that are antigen based and
they're they're getting prioritized
um so i think we're going to see more
and more antigen tests coming through
um you know i think where certainly
where a lot of the focus is going now
is towards uh you know self-testing uh
and direct consumer testing particularly
in in developed worlds
uh interpretation of tests uh
data handling data management you know
digitizing the
the system so we have good access to
good data quickly
um and that's where a lot of the the
development effort now
um seems to be headed over and above the
the assay itself
great thank you thank you brandon
um one of the topic that has been really
high on the
news back in the second quarter this was
this notion of
bringing some manufacturing home
developing domestic capacity
as a way to address a shortage of tests
but also i guess as a bit of a
protective
uh productive posture from in in some
places
any any thoughts about whether
this you know domestic manufacturing has
a future will actually
happen um maybe i'll turn back to you
david from avacta if you have any any
any thoughts on that
um will it actually happen
um okay well i think uh
we're doing well certainly here in the
uk we are doing
what we can um to make it happen so
there is
a very very active engagement between
government and industry um to
identify what needs to happen um
in order to establish
a national well they call it a sovereign
supply
effectively so the country as a as a as
a strategic objective
um and i'm sure all countries have the
same strategic objective
is to you know try and ensure that the
supply of of tests comes from a home
a home source and they're not reliant on
any overseas
supply of a critical raw material or any
any manufacturing capability
um so there is a significant effort
underway to build
that home-based manufacturing capacity
can it be done um quickly enough and to
the
to the right scale i think that remains
to be seen but that the intention is
definitely there
and that's been a very uh that's been a
very unique experience um
uh as a diagnostics company working in
that process
um because you know governments can
bring things to bear
um uh that you know the companies
themselves would struggle to
much more quickly and at a scale that's
not
otherwise possible um so yeah the
intention's there
um is it achievable i hope so
it's it's certainly a huge um a huge
challenge
um and you know what does it mean
for someone like a vacta so there's so i
just talked about the manufacturing but
um if you think of the whole supply like
the supply of the test i think in the
short term it means
as a uk based company it means that we
could potentially
um have a very big customer for um
for our for our one or more of our tests
uh a customer that could take subs you
know a substantial proportion of
everything we produce
or even everything we produce um
or nothing so it's a it's it's uh
you know potentially a great opportunity
and also quite risky
um so it it it does lead to some
interesting conversations on
you know sales channels and so forth and
uh and routes to market and commercial
and how we commercialize the test
i think in the longer term um what it
does demonstrate
is that governments have recognized the
strategic value
of a strong national diagnostics
industry
and they see the value of diagnostics as
a as a tool um to help tackle
these global and national health care
crises um and they also see the value in
establishing and growing the industry
so that it's better prepared next time
and to respond quickly and at scale
and for the next pandemic and by the way
there are there are other global
healthcare crises ongoing right now
maybe not they don't qualify as a
pandemic
um but things like antimicrobial
resistance the growth in
in in that and diagnostics have a
central role to play in how we um how we
tackle that
and i think that the recognition of that
and will um will will also be one of the
enduring legacies of
of the covenant 19 pandemic is the the
role of diagnostics and
helping tackle those sorts of crises as
well
thank you any any other thoughts from
anyone on this
notion of local manufacturing brandon i
see you
raising your voice yeah um yeah
yeah it's something we've actually been
been very focused on for
for the last six months um so
you know obviously the the the the ramp
to scale
in in anywhere where the the
infrastructure already infrastructure
doesn't exist it's long and it's
and it's difficult um if when it comes
to the immuno side certainly
it's it's it's a difficult technology to
manufacture at scale
um so you know to to greenfield's
uh new manufacturing capability
in in completely new environments is a
difficult thing to do
um you know one of the things we've been
working heavily
with with with the foundations on is
actually
this topic of of how we how we take
you know effectively a good set of sops
for
for for antigen assays or antibody
assays and distributing them broadly to
manufacturing entities with capability
for manufacturing at scale for low and
middle income
countries specifically um and you know
there's initiatives like the act a
initiative out of europe that are
spearheaded by fines that are very much
focused on doing
exactly that um and you know it again
it's it's not a simple thing to do it's
it's something that's
for for other other other public health
initiatives
has been attempted through the years and
hasn't been perhaps as successful as
people might want it to be um but again
the environment's different now i think
the
the funding is there the will is there
uh a longer-term view is there and i and
i think there's a
there's a an understanding now of
i suppose what what could happen again
in the next pandemic where
there is a global response required and
a very sizable proportion of the world's
population is left without good
good diagnostics um so i think i think
that will is there now and i think
there's a longer term
and that's something that we're working
on we're actually making our assets
available to those initiatives
um you know so that they can be
implemented in in
low and middle income country
manufacturing environments and and
helping with that process of training
and
establishing science doing that kind of
production so
we don't imagine it's simple uh but
we're trying to learn from the mistakes
of the past there too
thanks dave dave ginge drives
david sofia danny in your thoughts on
that topic
um not strong views i mean we are we do
all our manufacturing in the uk
um so i guess we were already homegrown
um i guess to be a little bit of a
devil's advocate i guess what i would
worry about
is you know when when we when and if we
emerge from this
um you know governments will be in debt
you know very much in debt from what
it's cost to support this
and um i guess if we wanted to have
local manufacturing
in every country uh the ideal thing
would be that it made commercial sense
to do that
you know and it would exist already and
i think one of the reasons it doesn't is
because it doesn't make commercial sense
it needs
it would need to be supported
financially and so
to brendan's point i think you know will
will there be a longer term
view desire drive to to support
that and time will tell
yes dave you know for cepheid the
manufacturing challenges are unique
because of the high degree
of integration and automation required
to
manufacture our test cartridges
the test itself is very simple to run
but all the complexity is inside the
cartridge and that
requires integration of
of both lyophilized and wet reagents
along with plastic parts that have to be
sonically welded
uh and the expertise required to do that
is limited to two locations in the world
in
sunnyvale california in silicon valley
and
uh at our site near stockholm so
when we have a sudden requirement for
additional
uh manufacturing uh capability it comes
at the cost
of increasing our shift coverage for our
existing facilities and
beyond that we would have to build a new
facility
to be able to scale so there's there's
sort of a
ceiling to what we can produce for
uh for our technology and that can only
be met by
expanding facilities and
manufacturing equipment we actually have
to manufacture our manufacturing
equipment
so the lag time in getting to scale
in a new facility uh is such that
uh it is can't happen quickly
uh despite you know throwing massive
amounts of money at it
it just can't so
i think our our challenge for the future
is to expand
manufacturing organically into other
countries to provide local
uh manufacturing capability but that
will take
time and hopefully we can leverage that
in the future
uh should this happen again but it
doesn't happen
thank you i'd like to maybe move to uh
preparedness which we touched
on a little bit earlier with you uh dave
at safiyad
um dave at gene drive
any any thoughts on preparedness for
a possible future future pandemic
i guess it depends on what on what the
pandemic is
um i think dave personally made a very
good point that i think in
the nucleic acid the pcr world
um again depending on what it is um you
know we're reasonably well equipped
to be nimble to deal with these sorts of
things when you move to other
technologies it does become
more difficult and i think um you know
preparedness
um i think we've all demonstrated that
we can do things faster that we can take
more elements of risk in our business
uh and i hope those things stay within
how we
operate um i would like to see
probably more nimbleness in in
regulators
and i know and i'll make that at a
global level because i think some
regulators
have been great but um clearly they're
all overwhelmed
uh you know brendan commented about
eua's at 20 2800 in the queue
i mean it's it's an astronomical number
isn't it
um so i think for it would it would be
nice in the future to see
maybe some of the more streamlined
regulations that have been put into
place whether
you know there's an opportunity to keep
some of those things uh in the future
and just for
for general working but ultimately
there's an element of luck in all of
this right are you in a company
that has a technology that can be
applied have you got the supply chain
have you got the capacity you know even
if you
you know and and again maybe maybe maybe
the person
might want to comment you know if you
need to change all your manufacturing to
deal with
something it means you're not dealing
with something else
right and the ability to just scale up
and you know
logarithmically produce more overnight
is is really is really a challenge but
i think we've all learned a lot now
about what we can do faster and more
nimbly
any other thoughts i mean dave anything
you want to add back to that
yeah i think it's a really good way of
saying it that
that you know for a company that has a
portfolio of tests
meeting the shifts in demand uh and
adjusting the the uh
production capacity to to
accommodate those shifts is very
important
and you know so for like virtually every
diagnostics company we saw major shifts
in demand
to work of it and away from things like
tuberculosis and chlamydia and gonorrhea
that will come at the price of public
health challenges in the future
they'll come at the price of increased
drug resistance increased complications
of
sexually transmitted infections
but we saw everyone saw drops in demand
for those tests and that did create
additional capacity for carnivorous
production
but now that we're back uh to meeting
meeting
needing to meet the needs of those other
conditions
now we're faced with increasing demand
for those
mainstay tests that we're going to
portfolio on top of the carbon virus
capacity that we have to meet
and i think it's important to maintain
flexibility
uh in that uh and also to
um be able to uh
realize that the next time this happens
and we're probably gonna see the same
phenomenon we're gonna see
a shift in in all the focus
and attention of shifting toward testing
for the new pandemic and away from
chronic conditions uh lifestyle related
conditions
and uh that the attitude will be well
those can wait
uh but they can only wait so long and uh
you know the frequency of viral load
testing for hiv
can only wait so long so bottom line is
that
there's also some accommodation on the
public health side that needs to happen
as well and we hope to be able to beat
those demands as they shift
thank you thank you dave sophie
should we pause for a question
yes i'll open the floor and um if anyone
has a question they can
unmute themselves and ask i thought we
we got a lot of interesting
info there about you know improving
access
and possibly things that were going to
be
neglected in in in favor of covid so i
have a question but i'll first
open it up to see if anyone else does
so i just have a question about um this
whole concept of serial testing
to help mitigate some of the concerns
with the sensitivity
and specificity of some of the rapid
tests
is that something that's likely to be
implemented more
it seems like a good way to go to
improve
performance um but we're not seeing a
lot of it done
so i'm just i just want to get your
views on is is that going to be
important
and why aren't we seeing more of it if
it is
yeah in the case of coronavirus i think
it is going to be important to
supplement the lower sensitivity of the
ancient tests with perfect
testing but i think you're right the
actual implementation of that increased
frequency
is far more challenging and far more
difficult to implement than
originally appreciate it theoretically
if you have a test that
is good at telling you that you are
infectious now
um that's important information
uh but it also uh indicates that
others may have been exposed prior to
getting that test result because
of the uh the possibility of infectivity
uh being present for perhaps days prior
to getting that test result
so nucleic acid tests are probably
really good at
identifying the first possible signs of
infection
maybe within two days after exposure
we'll see evidence of nucleic acid test
positivity
and that would predict two or three days
of
further incubation on getting becoming
infectious so there's an intervention
window
that you have to work with before you
um need to act on that test result
that window is much shorter for engine
tests
and it's going to be really valuable for
short-term
window prediction like getting on a
four-hour flight
for instance or getting on a six-hour
getting involved in a
in a four or six hour sports event
uh for instance in a crowd but the
bottom line is that
that it it needs to be used for what
it's good at
and in order to make it good at
detecting
uh infectious cases with an adequate
uh intervention window it has to be done
frequently and i think that's
where we're seeing the shortfall right
now is that
there may be almost an assumption that
if i tested negative
that i'm good to go and i don't need to
come back and it may be
maybe a compliance issue on the
patient's side
well i just tested negative yesterday do
i really need to get re-tested
these issues will come up i think uh
relative to the to test frequency
thank you great any more questions here
one of the let me just make one comment
on
uh that was referred to earlier i think
the uh one of the
indirect uh effects of
covid is going to be on coming up with
better tools for dealing with sepsis
never before have we realized in the
medical community
that viruses can cause sepsis
uh we've known that uh we sort of the
sepsis docs have known this for years
but
it hasn't been widely appreciated that
any severe
viral infection whether it's influenza
rsv
or carnovirus can cause a sepsis-like
presentation
and so i think one of the indirect
effects of coke
is going to help us justify improving
diagnostic tools managing sepsis
patients
uh especially presenting in the
emergency room setting
and um so we're likely to see a lot of
that
play out over the next couple of years
that
we will actually see significant benefit
in
coming up with better ways to stratify
patients coming in with
sepsis-like presentations
so thank you dave sofiani
any more questions i think we're getting
to the top of the hour so
maybe we start wrapping up the end so i
think
go to the lightning round yeah i know i
think so you know some of the takeaways
and first of all thanks a lot for
uh for joining thanks to uh
the three daves and and brandon for your
insights i think you know we talked
about
the response of the industry the
capability and what the industry has
demonstrated has
been willing to partner and work
together
we talked about leveraging and
repurposing
existing tools to go faster in the
future
and we talked about uh localization and
closer to home manufacturing is a
possibility but
uh needs certainly um the
guidance and and and help from
government and organization to help
bridge the economic challenge that
that that is there we talked a lot about
the the mix
between pcr and rapid testing and the
need for more rapid testing but in in
good combination with the the ptr based
base test and i think you know great
discussion on preparedness
uh how do we have roads broader range of
assay may be
ready available but also challenges that
goes with any pandemic of that
of that sort um any what i'd like is
maybe go back and do another
final lightning round for anything that
uh you'd like
anyone would like to add uh any further
learning anything we have not covered
uh for for the for the future so maybe
i'll go back to you uh
dave we'll do it in the same order david
cepheus any any final thought
yeah i i think that you know getting
back to the point of getting ready for
the future
it's going to be increasingly important
to develop
sort of universal diagnostics capacity
that can be adapted quickly
to a new pandemic threat and with
nucleic acid testing
we can do that we can actually stockpile
universal cartridges and universal
reagents and adapt those quickly
to the uh to the new targets
um and i think that will really help us
be able to respond more quickly
um but we have to think creatively about
how we do this
and um and what we need to get ready for
dave gene drive um
i think i think for for me the lasting
changes are going to be just around the
recognition
of the diagnostics industry you know
within government
and finance business general public i
mean
my sort of local social media groups
you know people talk about pcr testing
and you know
who whoever would have thought that ever
would have happened you know
um but there's you know clearly a much
higher level of interest of investment
um a focus on on the industry and the
industry players
and i think that can't be anything but
positive
david yeah nothing
new really to add to that um i'll just
finish where i started i think
um the fact that diagnostic testing the
value of diagnostic testing is now
acknowledged as a as a tool
um a critical tool for tackling these
global
crises and also the recognition
of the strong industry national industry
as a key strategic asset
i mean the uk government actually said
that one of the reasons they felt that
they were slower than some countries to
respond was because they had a weaker
diagnostics industry and they've they've
explicitly stated that they want that
to change and that what will come out of
this will be a stronger
diagnostics industry um so i think that
will be a very positive and enduring uh
legacy
uh from this and also to reiterate what
dave dave bud said um it's just
it's just a unique time when you pick up
national newspapers and
listen to the national news on tv and
people are talking about test
specificity and test sensitivity and
predictive values and it's you know it's
a it's never happened before
so i think we've i think the industries
finally come out of the shadows of the
other
uh healthcare sectors and uh and and
should hopefully uh benefit from
recognition of the value that it really
does deliver
talking about testing at the pub in the
evening right yeah yeah yeah
that's a new thing right exactly yeah
brandon final thoughts please
between cpr and pcr
um but you know i i i think with that i
suppose with with that
um new focus i suppose on diagnostics
as a as a thing of importance um
you know i hope out of all of this
there's the the there will be
some degree of of patience learned uh
and
that you know in in the in the responses
both from government and from industry
that um you know people follow the
science
you know and and i think going back to
the question on sequential testing
um you know it's a good it's a good
thing to stop and examine the use cases
relative to the capabilities of these
tests right and you know
for for antigen tests you know antigen
tests no matter how sensitive they are
are still much more likely to give a
false positive in a low intensity
environment then give a correct
answer right so to their use off-label
if you will in places like
airports and train stations and things
like that in europe which is happening
now
um you know it it it yeah it's an
understandable human response but
you know i i i hope ultimately out of
this a little more understanding of the
science will
trickle out into the into the broader
world and into the governments as well
um i think that could be a very valuable
thing in the long term
thank you very much brandon thank you
all with that sophie do you want to
take it back yes thank you everyone
and so if we didn't get to your question
or if a question
occurs to you after we hang up here then
do get in contact with me and i can work
to get you an answer if you want a
follow-up discussion with any of our
panelists again
work through me i sent a link on the
chat to our diagnostics virtual summit
so it takes five minutes to register
if you want to go deeper on any of the
topics that we discussed today
so i wish we could have got together in
person for this
discussion uh another time hopefully uh
with some strong testing behind us so i
hope this has been
insightful for you all and we at sativa
i look forward to working with you going
forwards
thanks everyone thank you
thank you thank you thanks very much
thanks sophie
bye bye everybody